What would happen if a germ cell went through
mitosis? Now think about it for a second. Mitosis
results in two cells that have the same number
of chromosomes that the parent cell had, 46 chromosomes.
This means that the germ cell would be making
two gametes each with 46 chromosomes. If a sperm
with 46 chromosomes fertilizes an egg that also has
46 chromosomes, then that would result in a cell with
92 chromosomes. That's twice as much as human
cells are supposed to have. If we take this
to its logical conclusion, while the first humans
would have 46 chromosomes, the next generation would have
92 and the next generation would have 184.
And the next generation would have 368, and so
forth and so on. We would just be in
this endless arms race, doubling our chromosomes every generation.
So this, just doesn't work. Germ cells go
through a very special kind of division, called meiosis.
And this division is different from every other cell
type in your body. And the reason is specifically,
to solve this problem of having too many chromosomes
at fertilization. What happens is DNAs duplicated just like
in mitosis, but then there's a round of cell
division. And then the resulting cells, without duplicating their
DNA again, go through another round of cell division and in this case we
separate out. Every chromosome now, is not in a pair. The
pairs have been broken up. How many chromosomes would a gamete have
after meiosis? Go ahead and put your, numerical answer in this box here.